[Music]
welcome back to the Ingram angle as
we've been reporting we should be
thankful for the economic rebound that
President Trump has helped usher in
during his first year in office this is
not what the experts or mr. Trump's
critics predicted if the unlikely event
happens and Trump wins you will see a
market crash of historic proportions in
the event Donald wins I have no doubt in
my mind the the market tanks if the
polls look like there's a decent chance
that Donald could win I'll put a huge
hedge on that's over a hundred percent
of my equity positions and my bond
position as well that protects me just
in case he wins I'm worried about it um
you know I'm not gonna sugarcoat it I'm
a free trader TPP is good for American
business I think nap it was good for
American business but you you can't get
everything in life you want unbelievable
I love those montages I think I want
just that for Christmas I don't need
anything else well it hasn't turned out
that way has it everything hasn't crater
the world hasn't come to an end
unemployment is down blue-collar wages
are rising the stock market is booming
all because America first policies do
work and not the problem while the
experts were predicting and in the
latest sign of a booming economy human
resources officers from some 500
corporations are anticipating get this I
saw this this morning a massive 66%
increase in cash Christmas bonuses that
adds up to a big surge in gifts and
parties and frankly happiness for
American workers you know it supposed to
be the pursuit of happiness too that
would be nice
even the president's lefty critics are
coming around to the new realities our
neighbors to the north at the Toronto
Star at least one prominent columnist is
noting this about the president's
negotiations on trade in a piece titled
believe it or not on NAFTA Donald Trump
makes sense and in the Economist this
blaring headline all those kind of
grudging blue-collar wages are surging
like
they don't want to give Trump credit but
I'll take the headline so what about the
never Trump errs who only pay lip
service to the will of the voters well
we're starting to get an idea of what
they really think here's what Weekly
Standard editor at large Bill Kristol
tweeted out last night he said the GOP
tax bill is bringing out my inner
socialist the sex scandals are bringing
out my inner feminist and Donald Trump
and Roy Moore are bringing out my inner
liberal what's happening well what's
happening bill is that we now can see
that you know you're not that
conservative stalwart we thought you
were before the election of Donald Trump
well this year has been filled with a
lot of political revelations and the
people you thought you knew on the left
and on the right are coming into clear
focus for many people and as for
president Trump's tweets well sometimes
they can be a little bit
self-destructive or distracting that's
true
but I say this at least we now have an
unvarnished view of what the leader of
the free world really thinks about
issues big and small I actually think
that's kind of refreshing and how many
Twitter accounts can drive a news cycle
all by their lonesome and he has a
direct conduit a direct pipeline to the
American people which of course drives
the old lame stream media nuts because
they want to control the information
you're getting president Trump says uh
I'm gonna have my say I'm gonna go right
to the people with it joining us now for
reaction from Mobile Alabama my old
friend Quinn Hillier a contributing
editor at National Review and in New
York another old friend owns old but
your dear friends Andy Stein a Democrat
and a former president of the New York
City Council it is great to see both of
you happy Thanksgiving Thank You Laura
thank you thank you Andy on this I
personally am really grateful that we
have president Trump in office that
Hillary is not president that we have an
economy that is looks like it's in the
midst of a real recovery not a anemic
flatlining recovery as we saw under
President Obama do you agree with that
or am I kind of looking at things way
too optimistically at this point well
war
first of all happy Thanksgiving when I
in it when I met Donald Trump in 1973 a
mutual friend called to ask us to have
to have dinner he is the exact same
person as he was then and isn't it
refreshing to have someone who is really
honest and says what he thinks
sure occasionally he may put his foot in
his mouth but I think that he's done so
well the economy is really strong I mean
the this is two trillion dollars that is
in the pocket of working men and women
we defeated Isis in in Raqqa and there's
no more talk about a caliphate he's
reduced all these regulations I think
he's doing a terrific job and you know
when I first endorsed them in The Wall
Street Journal in September of 2016
the people in Manhattan everywhere I'd
go would say how could you do that he's
this he's that I mean you have no idea
you played the Steve Rattner some of
these other now they went insane but the
truth is that Trump is an extremely
caring sensitive guy you know when my
father was sick and dying he would call
couple times a week to see how he was
the same with Bob crafts wife the same
with David don't know that about him
Andy a lot of people don't know that
about him Quinn I know you weren't a big
fan to say the least of Donald Trump
during the primary you didn't want him
to be the nominee well now he's been
president for 11 months the the economic
rebound that even even some of his
harshest critics have to admit is here
what do you think now are you grateful
that Hillary is not president are you
still kind of on the fence about how
Trump's stewarding the economy no of
course I'm grateful that Hillary is not
president that was never in question I
never wanted her I fought her for 25
years I still remain a
of Trump personally I think his tweets
are not refreshing I think they are
horrendous but you mentioned the economy
and while I think it's foolish to give
him all the credit for the good economy
it would also be absolutely unfair not
to give him a significant amount of